oh sorry is your time so precious such
an old guy you know I'm sorry you've got
a 14. you got a whole bunch of
stuff to do you got a whole lot of
videos
who cares what you got to do in your
life I'm gonna pause for as long
as I want
[Music]
hello hello hello
hello
let's let's see what you got going on
here
nice you look good
you look good you know what I thought
when you walked in my ass what
that you never wear red and you look
good in red thanks you know I don't
really wear red
I don't wear red ever no yeah mom always
said I look good in red
she was right she was she was right I
guess I don't wear red because it's such
a like
hey well not that I don't wear hey look
at me clothes but I don't know it always
feels like a hey look at me color to me
and why is that always stopped you you
always wear I know I don't know well you
know what it comes from to me honestly
the reason why I don't want to wear red
is because I genuinely dislike red cars
that's I think why what you know you're
not a car
you never know I have had people inside
me
um and you know I go 100 miles an hour
baby
I was so dumb
I spoke with somebody who used to be a
uh a
okay
and he was talking about wearing red
yeah
just can't do it oh you told me this
yeah that's crazy huh and you told me
what is it to see they can't say oh yeah
they they don't say like they don't say
cool they'll say oh wait wait with a
Crips will all I know is that they say
instead of like cool they'll say bull
no the Bloods yeah yeah Bloods won't
even use words man I'm so branky well I
follow this guy on Instagram named still
brazy oh yeah oh yeah follow him too
wait I told you about him right I don't
think so oh no I totally talked about
this yeah yeah okay yeah but because
it's crazy no idea what it meant brazy
is crazy yeah but I guess he used to be
a uh oh is that right yeah but I go
brazy you know I'm brazy I go I'm brazy
as hell I go brazy but
um yeah
favorite filmmaker mine's Wes Braven
um wow I feel that uh well
mine is Christopher Nolan so I uh
nah but anyway dude episode 76 wow mine
is Alfred Hitchcock yeah
oh yeah Bach
[Laughter]
I can't believe how long it took me to
know what to do is when Bloods get some
dumb ah subuk my Bach
so episode 76 Sunday uh it's yay hey
Sunday's upper Lifeline uh go sign up
for Lifeline luxury patreon.com Lifeline
luxury you know we got those brazy
episodes on and we got those braziabs on
there uh it's the best show it's the
it's the cast what I don't get is it is
the best show should be getting millions
and millions and millions of hits
um yeah live on luxury and we go hit it
up uh you can go see me on tour where am
I going to be I'm gonna be in Cleveland
and Pittsburgh and uh Fort Myers and
Orlando and uh reading and Philadelphia
and uh Virginia I always forget that one
Virginia but I am all right I'm gonna be
a return I got them I am going to be
aren't I in that crazy wow yep it's just
some a soup of words with no space you
got question click on the link
description below go to watch Lifeline
or go to watch lifestyle.com you also
can hit the uh you can dial the number
and leave a message anonymously on our
hotline
um but yeah send us a video we love
hearing from you you're great we love
follow-up videos and we love new videos
too from the new people you want a
one-on-one session do you well you
should watch confrontational and if you
do want one because you should want one
you should book one with me at
matalia.com
your secret to safe with me uh and if
you want the merch get it all at
lifelinemarsh.com
you're gonna look good in it I guarantee
it
wait not like a legally binding
guarantee
it would be not box just was thinking
about that
um
that's gangster to be like I can't even
put it with a CK yeah yeah the babadook
it's just about that's like a Crips dick
or a blood stick that's a good movie no
it's not oh oh really it's not it's not
about that okay that movie is not about
a Crips dybic well dibik is the real
thing it is and divick should be up I'm
sure it's a Harmony you wish my buddy
there is a movie called The DivX yeah
I'm sure about recent my buddy has a uh
the shoe company called and they makes
really good shoes oh yeah with that
Donnie is it up yep
um go look at this stuff anyway with the
dice yes I've seen him so uh
actually you know what I know I told you
this but there's an addendum to this
story and I know you know this I think I
told it in the lifeline group chat
all right I'll just tell it yeah we
don't know what it is yet you do once I
start it right now I don't know what it
is I know but everyone needs to know
okay
I'm having a conversation
with Kristen on the patio of the coffee
shop block I used to run
that used to be the Coffee Bean and Tea
Leaf and now it's an Alfred's coffee
okay so it's better but you think it's
worse it's worse right it's better 99.9
of the population would say it's better
you are in the 0.1 percent that would
say it's worse okay because I'm a genius
and so so we're we're having a
conversation Kristen is looking at me
and I'm looking to her and I am facing
the street you know where this is going
I do I think I do yeah yeah
um
a car
pulls up on the street and stops because
it's at it's waiting for a red light
okay I'm talking to Christian she's
telling me something important actually
to where
I I can rack Focus behind her and I see
the window is open in the passenger seat
and inside is somebody staring at me and
as Iraq Focus I see it's Bruce Willis
okay question okay at this point you say
oh I didn't say that yet in your mind
uh-huh uh in you how much and how
quickly rather did you absolutely know
for sure instantaneously just
immediately it was immediately that was
does Bruce was you know why
because he was looking directly at me I
made eye contact with him and he was he
was actually doing his Bruce Willis
smirk where he was like yeah I can't do
it but you know I'm talking about he's
being Bruce he's being Bruce Willis okay
got it so I she's telling me something
important and actually emotional okay oh
no so I'm seeing now I'm seeing Bruce
Willis oh God okay what a dilemma yeah
yeah so I'm like oh I don't know
what to do that's terrible but and I
actually think I need to be here for her
but but she'd want to see Bruce Willis
but you also also you got to be there
for Bruce too he's looking right at you
something's going on right so I'm like
now in my head I'm like is Bruce Willis
famous enough
to where I should stop this and tell
Kristen about it okay and because if it
was Berry pepper I would just tell her
later afterwards no offense to Berry
pepper no we like we love you Giovanni
Ribisi I probably wouldn't do it either
no way anybody from favorite Ryan from
Brian besides Matt Damon and Tom Hanks I
don't think I'd do it
so so I'm like
I gotta say something and I say I'm
sorry babe but that's Bruce Willis yeah
he's one of the most giant movie stars
he's one of those giant movie stars of
all time there's no doubt you have to
stop her and say yeah and I'm a huge fan
of you yeah you are yeah right yeah so I
say I'm sorry I'm sorry babe but that's
Bruce Willis and she looks over okay and
Bruce Willis is still staring directly
at me and how close are we talking to
him let's see uh how far would you say
that wall is over there
30 30 40 feet okay so 35 yeah something
like that 60 feet
twice oh that's close though yeah it's
very close yeah yeah okay so he's 60
feet away and then I I he's looking at
me and I say that's Bruce Willis I guess
I say it loud enough yeah which I really
didn't try to but a few of the people
around me go like this
so now yeah Bruce will look at me
everybody's looking at Bruce Willis okay
on the patio okay
so now I'm like I have to say something
I guess because I don't I don't know why
he's looking at me all right and he's
not looking away at any point he's just
staring no dude he is not looking away
at any point he's just staring at me
you're not weirded out even a little bit
very interested in what is happening
what is going on here yeah why is he
staring at me yeah did he just watch my
Netflix special it's like this kind of
thing where I'm like did he just see a
clip of mine or something or or do I
look like a guy that like his ex
like this is always looking at me right
okay so I say to him
allowed because now everybody's kind of
involved in a way and I want to jump
past the part of awkwardness and I can
do it like this and I say
hey man
we all love you right and I say that
that loud because I want him to know
because I know he's also going through
that thing with with the brain fog and
all that he's doing well yeah he's not
doing so well but I gotta tell you
something
he looks fantastic he looks he's Bruce
he looks fantastic but you know you you
know you sometimes you see a guy after
you haven't seen him in a while and
you're like oh they look really old yeah
he looks great he looks great okay so I
say hey man we all love you and
everyone's looking at him and he leans
out of the car yeah
and he goes like this
that much A lot
okay you told the story wrong dude but
first you build it on text I know but
tonight how could I how could I get this
through text there's no way just that
part voice noted yeah no but so you
didn't do enough O's I wanted to do it
on the podcast all right then say that
I'm out
and that's it and then
the guy who's driving him that looks
like Akon by the way is just like he's
he's going like this
pointing at me
and Bruce was like
and there
so he's literally just says no words no
words only Woos
that's and then later on I'm telling the
story Rick recalling it to Kristen and
someone else and Chris is like well he
was looking at me and I'm like oh dude
it's possible now
it's not how do you know
I guess maybe because her back was to
him right wow hey
come here and I was staring at him from
the beginning and end
she was here I was here Bruce was there
so when she turned around boom it looked
like she was looking back into the left
back and to the left that looked like he
was looking at her obviously he was
looking at me because I said the
thing and also took me in the beginning
so I get that okay no the best part was
no who's that guy from The Bear the
actor Jimmy Jeremy Allen White yeah
before the Bruce Willis thing
I walked by that guy
and I was looking at him as I was
walking by because when you're famous
and you see another famous guy you gotta
look at each other and be like
okay so I was walking by and I went to
go look at him and he didn't look at me
so I was like hey man
okay and then I went in and I got the
Bruce Willis thing uh maybe he didn't
see you though it was could have been
but but I walked right by him why and
then so jokes on him because I got the
Bruce Willis thing out yeah you you
don't even need him because you got the
biggest movie I was like yeah man that
sucks you know the bear guy didn't kind
of look at me and I was I was making
sure to I was ready for the famous to
receive the famous oh we are both in
this together you didn't even know his
name he's not on Bruce Willis's level so
yeah exactly and then and then I got the
Bruce Willis thing and then not only
that Bruce Willis was one that started
it and he also did the woo like for so
long according to you yeah was everyone
else like what is he doing
no because the whole thing was weird it
was like they were like I can't believe
we saw Bruce Willis okay for me this is
another day in the office you know but
for everyone else I get it wait but no I
I want to stick more with the crazy
wooing he did I don't know why he did
that
did he really do it for that long I
might have been doing it maybe I did two
Woo's extra
he did a lot of moves
that was fantastic is that part of his
thing well no I don't think it well I
here's the thing it he did not in any
way seem out of it oh or incoherent or
anything like that
he just seemed like he was having a fun
time maybe he was on drugs I don't know
I mean I have no idea about any of that
but yeah so that's what happened damn
but Kristen thinks it was for
it was for her and I you know it's just
like okay
anyway that's my story all right yeah
that's a pretty good story yeah thanks
yeah oh the addendum I didn't even take
the addendum there's an addendum there's
an addendum I said that there was gonna
be an addendum oh okay I thought that
was okay yeah dude I'm at a
grocery store today eating yeah
and I
I'm just eating I'm having a you know I
eat healthy I got caught I'm eating Cod
it doesn't matter the story but that
doesn't matter yeah eating at a grocery
store yeah that's what I'm doing Cod at
a grocery store dude dude are you 78
the eating Cod at a grocery store
the 78 years old
you know I I don't feel I don't feel
shame about it at all you shouldn't I'm
just saying that's yeah you're 78 okay
keep going I'm with two other people
okay okay famous
you're with them yeah I'm with them
they're famous oh yeah okay so three
famous people that doesn't matter the
story at all I know I'm just a lot of
this matters I'm coloring it like a
novelist talks about the clouds when
they're really the books about the guy
Dart
saying the parts that matter okay
I'm eating the Cod yeah
that doesn't seem like it matters but
but I kind of and I'm doing it and we're
having a conversation
Rumor Willis walks by his daughter
who we know this is a Willis
like for me
just like a heavy Willis week to Willis
Fest is that the whole story
just weird right that's not weird that's
not weird really that's not weird not
really
they're two different people you know
they're in the same family dude yeah but
they're not yeah yeah you don't think
it's weird if one day somebody sees
matly at the next day they say crystal
yeah uh it's weird there we go dude
it's a little weird yeah anyway dude
jokes on that Jimmy Page Allen guy I
wonder who you're gonna see you're gonna
see Demi tomorrow
or the other Bruce Willis Scout three I
think he has four they have four
daughters together I don't know lemonade
is a popular drink and it still is I get
more props since then Bruce Willis okay
shout out to Guru rest in peace oh he's
dead for a long long time damn rips man
so anyway was the man let's do it let's
do it
so dark hi Matt and Chris my fiance and
I watch you every week we love you guys
but my question is that we're getting
married in May and my stepdad wants to
have a father-daughter dance my real dad
probably not going to be okay with that
he's like typical hot-headed very
emotional Italian father and I think
he'd be hurt if I had a dance just
with my stepdad I think it would like
lessen the importance of the father real
father-daughter dance so you are gonna
have a father but my stepdad was has
been there since I was a kid he spent
money on the wedding and I want to do
something special for him too but I
don't want to one-up the father-daughter
dance so if you have any advice on what
I should do
um or any ideas on what to say to either
of them that would be super chill thank
you so much love you guys bye all right
here's the thing first of all a lot of
people say I don't know how to I don't
know how to tell the person that that's
a common thing people call in to show
you yeah it is true almost always the
answer is how you just said it yes yep
yep it's like there's no how would you
say it on Lifeline that's what you would
yeah that's the answer like you would
say it just the way you did it was
honest it made sense it was it was
respectful of everyone's feelings you
don't need to come up with this whole
way how do I do it how do I do it you
just did it just do it to a different
person that being said can't you just
have the father-daughter dance with your
real dad and then have like another nice
thing with your stepdad later that's
what I'm saying yeah like you have a
whole you its own thing don't have it
compete with your actual dad have it be
separate everyone can be happy and if
your real dad gets upset about that
we've got an on our hands well
honestly but he he's an Italian guy he's
a hot-headed Italian she said so he's
out also if this guy's paying for the
wedding like
why isn't your dad do it like come on
the guy came in every which way yeah I
know you're not dancing with your
stepdad right yeah I know you'd never do
that to me right yeah that's how it's
gonna be and then later and then
after that it's gonna be like and now
the dance with the stepdad and you're
gonna hear are you kidding me
from the back for Christ's sakes
this guy's not gonna pay and he's
dictating who you can dance with like no
this guy this guy come on you came from
my balls sweetheart and you're gonna
dance with somebody who's born
come from wow the speed his speech yeah
you know I was gonna come up here and
give a really great speech about my
daughter and how great she was I
remember times we were playing light
bright
on but
I'll tell you something man
this disrespectful all
right first of all her second of all
this no nuts all right she
came from my balls okay she came from my
balls all right I out in her
right there stand up stand up I know
we're not in good terms stand up point
that one
all right now this no nuts you stand up
you stand up Point your nuts you
shouldn't come from there you know where
she came from
this pulls out his nuts right there and
she's gonna disrespect her father me
she's gonna disrespect me let him come
out of my nuts I get a dance and then he
also gets a dance so what do I get
another dance here we go Bandit come
here daughter wow this ball's still out
play what I want this time Cisco wow
wow dude I don't think it'll go that
badly but just if it does
your real dad's dick yeah you know a lot
of times people yeah it's true yeah yeah
um
but yeah just have it to do its own your
own separate thing with the other guy
yeah it's only right he's been with you
since you were a little kid he paid for
a wedding and you love him
this is 2023 not everything's all cut
and dry perfect like it used to be I
mean all the things used to be perfect
but I mean like the family unit it's
sloppy it's messy that's how it is
though so now I get another dance invent
your own go hits play Sinatra come
on
all the kids are crying you know at the
wedding uh yeah
make up more people do that at
weddings anyway don't do like the
everyone's always done true make it
yours yeah all this
everyone's always yeah the Traditions
they're not your Traditions you know me
I don't believe in I don't like
traditions at all make sure you're all
having fun at your wedding the
everyone's enjoying themselves that's it
I went to a wedding this past I guess
two weekends ago well three weekends ago
when this comes out but um
it was great the way they did the thing
they they wanted to do
um
uh they wanted to not announce the
people when they come out afterwards and
they just all came out at once they're
like give it up for the bridal party and
the girls man and they just all ran out
it was really cool
like a sport like a like a yeah like a
sporting event
okay like Notre Dame or something I'm
clapping for that wedding yeah it was
good that was a good wedding dude shout
out to Donna Marielle um
and Marielle Don Muriel thanks Tom and
Mario yeah so anyway all right all right
next one so better you weren't in the
way that's great
hey boys I need some advice here so uh
my co-worker is like 45 and I'm 27.
he's nice he's really really nice
just get the feeling that he needs a lot
of attention like grew up military kid
traveled around a lot I don't know that
he had a lot of friends because he just
does not seem socially aware and there's
days that I have a lot of capacity for
it and I can shoot the and then
there's days I just don't and I end up
kind of like ex not exploding but
snapping being like very rude oh how do
I handle it man like it's legitimately
he's an older person but he'll come in
being like he'll ask you questions that
he's wanting you to ask him the
questions
get a lot of sleep and you're like yes
and he's like mine did and you're like
oh here we go now we're going in
this guy's fine and I swear to god dude
the other day he said blast as I like
upset he was like
who the does that man
love you guys thank you this guy's funny
I like this guy you're mad at the wrong
things here I don't
I like blast dude say whatever you want
no here's but but but here's the thing
you need to develop a relationship with
this guy where it's okay for you to be
like why are you doing this
that's exactly right and you can do it
in a humorous way it might be too late
now to do that but you can also just do
it in a boundaries actual way and be
like hey which I don't I'm not I'm a big
fan on not you know just being making a
joke about it I got problems so but but
you can
um you can do that you should do it
you're funny though he should have done
that already you're saying he but what
do you mean the boundary you're saying
he can say look like I'm this and this
and you're like hey man
you know I don't like when this happens
I like you but like why do you do this
you don't have to do that like yeah you
know yeah God that's hard because you're
telling somebody what their like issues
are kind of kind of I mean try to do it
try to do it like it makes me feel from
that track I agree though start just
like you're obviously a funny guy in a
funny way be like what the like why
do you do this like what try that yeah
just try it it'll also help her I know
you like you just want to tell me about
your weekend so like go ahead what are
you doing yeah don't make me answer
first I know and you might be funny dude
you might feel weird about it doing it
the first few times but also that makes
you funnier because you know while
you're doing it signal to him that you
are also having fun with it here's the
other thing though you've got to learn
he's his boss right uh no he's a
co-worker okay you got then even just
the same you gotta you gotta coexist
with this person yeah so you they're
your choice so you don't want to just
like be irate all the time like you are
you son of a why do you
break up my kids sleep when you know I
wanna
you gotta just learn how to have fun
with it like lean into how ridiculous
the person is and have fun collecting
stories about him so you can talk
about him when he's not around
walk here's what you do next time you
see him say hey gotta ask you why did
you say blast is it yeah yeah yeah is it
the 1940s yeah yeah he'll like that yeah
he'll laugh at that I I hope he would if
he didn't then that's crazy yeah or you
could be like dude congratulations it's
crazy but you look fantastic for your
age and he'll say like really how old do
you think I look and then say 45 and
then when he says I am 45 say that can't
be you said blast you're at least 90.
so long to get to the punch down
um yeah blast huh that's pretty funny
though the guy that I'm gonna start
saying black I like that guy I'm gonna
be 45 in a few years though so I like
that guy but I look great the co-worker
what but I look great
it's all right
all right yeah breathe in breathe out I
had that stick in my head because you
said lean in and now I'm thinking of
that
great
one of those things huh
I mean
that could be it could be a far it could
be a thing all right all right
hey man whoa cute Sarah in autumn
coming to you from Connecticut
um I am looking for advice not for me
but for my fiance
um I love him dearly I want to preface
with that he goes on uh paternity leave
uh when mine ends and I work from home
okay and I need you to give him advices
on what he can do on his paternity leave
so he doesn't drive me nuts and I say
that with all of the love
um right
all of the advices you give funny
serious
um we love you we watch the show
together so I hope he enjoys watching
this
um can't wait to see you come to
Connecticut soon
um Matt we love you as well so does
autumn
um see you guys soon thanks look at how
cute that baby babies are never that
cute yeah well no you know what it is
baby you know what it is that baby is so
close to birth that they're not usually
cute yet that's what I'm saying yeah
yeah but I'm saying you're way better
newborns I'm saying it just like like
scores better wait what are you saying
I'm saying it like League's better than
you are no I'm saying babies at that age
are never cute that baby's insanely cute
that's what you said now but what you
said then which was what which was that
baby's really cute wow and then I said
it leagues no you just didn't hear me I
said babies are never cute yeah that's
what you did say but I'm saying it leaks
better being like Oh baby's that age or
never that cute you mean newborns yeah
yes which is a better way to say it even
still close to birth newborns
are always
ugly or look like aliens I don't I don't
one or the other I don't agree the ugly
thing I think that the I think that it
is it's cute in that sense that's a
that's a personal yeah it is a person
that's a taste though yeah I'm saying
like objectively they're like they do
looking things yes they they look very
well they look non-human right well also
think about it though like they just
went through the most traumatic thing
ever yep their faces are red
women like bouncing around birth
for me but then in the in 2020 it was
harder but yeah cool man uh yeah so what
about I'll tell you what I'd rather be
born again than go through that show
okay what I'm saying but anyway yeah
Vice for
Autumn's dad oh who's that almost died
dude how to not drive his wife crazy in
the money well I think it I think I
think it I think it falls a little bit
more on you I think you need to set some
sort of God I hate this word but
boundaries you need to set some sort of
this is my work area this is my work
room this is when I'm working when I'm
working here don't bother me unless it's
an emergency right don't just be like
where are the diapers you find
them right or whatever I don't know what
kind of relationship they have with the
you know if it's 50 50 or if it's like
it sounds like a 50 50 if he's taking
paternity leave but
um yeah I think that it falls more on
you to be like yo this is my space I
gotta work from now to now take care of
this don't come to me unless
somebody's bleeding okay there's that
but there's also for him I would say the
advice is probably something like
you're gonna not know what to do because
not only are you off of work and you're
usually at work but you have all this
free time but you also have a newborn
baby and you have no experience with
those things and that's difficult right
and then you have your wife who on top
of that just went through Labor and is
recovering from that and a lot of other
going on hormonally it's like it's
crazy time
do
the things that are expected of you ask
if you can do more whatever those things
are do them
and then once that's done
get the away
because you're going to be annoying if
anyone ever you're going to be that way
I would be out I'll tell you okay and
here's the other thing she's asking the
question wrong she's saying how do I
give my advice no I know I know I'm
giving advice to him no I know yeah but
she's saying how
do I give advice to my
how do you or I give advice to
uh like you us or I her she gives advice
to my husband to not drive me crazy the
advice should be how do I make sure my
husband doesn't drive me crazy when he's
home from paternity leave but I'm
telling you that because that's much
better okay but she watches it with her
husband they're gonna watch it he's
gonna watch it so she's calling for him
okay
but she made very clear what you weren't
listening no no I do know that but I'm
just saying hey dude she's about to tell
you something now then just now you look
at him and tell him what I just said
about you to hey this is my workspace
and I'll just do it she has her own
workspace and also
figure it out unless someone's bleeding
wow so that was totally unnecessary
which is all good but uh yeah man just
stay away and stop don't annoy just in
general don't know someone who's just
been through something really really
crazy uh like birth
no I don't yeah for the mother yeah
yeah for the mother
also help just help what's up Chris and
Matt I love the show let's get right to
it what do you say or do to someone who
is
chewing works at the 76ers
ridiculously loud oh yeah that it makes
you want to do violence on that person
it's tough
uh got a co-worker I'm with him every
now and then and uh I mean we're
literally stuck in this tiny van
together
one time's the worst usually eating with
the clinch fist yeah let me know what I
can do yeah that's tough dude I'd eat
outside of the van I think honestly
that's disgusting you have to say
something yeah for sure you gotta say
like
because sometimes honestly okay so this
is this guy would love it if in
particularly that guy he's talking about
saw this and wasn't didn't know he was
going to be seeing it and he'd just be
like oh oh the chore yeah yeah for sure
yeah because you know it's him because
he knows he sits there so I
have done this before I've
I asked somebody once who I was eating
around a lot yeah why they
choose the way that they chew yeah
because it always bothered the hell out
of me and it was like
you know when you see somebody
chewing with their mouth full yeah
you're like well were you never a kid
yeah yeah when I was a kid 20. because
when I was a kid if I ever made that
mistake for half of a chew yeah some
adult would have been there and said
don't you with your mouth 100 and Susie
be like close your mouth when you chew
right so if you
skipped all that like how did how did
you you couldn't possibly skip that so
you must have not been a child yep they
weren't children you were born at 20.
same to the guy yeah exactly
just so round about our advice for this
this episode you were born at 20 what
well because you couldn't have been a
kid right what are you talking about so
when you're a kid and you're doing
things that you aren't supposed to be
doing right
don't stop you
I mean you chew with your mouth this
would be pretty good way actually yeah
yeah yeah in all honesty that would be
great but um yeah like it's just it's
it's it's this anyway what I did I
brought it up and I said
I don't remember exactly how I said but
it was rude it's rude because when you
confront somebody like that sometimes
there's no way to not be rude yeah my
issue is that sometimes I know that and
I lean into the rudeness because I'm
like we both know rude is coming right
right right and I like that you know
what I mean I appreciate it yeah cool
thanks you're the only one and uh you
know I'm like that so
what happened is the person said back to
me an actual reason then I felt bad yeah
yep they they have something that's
something with their mouth where like
they
to actually close their mouth and chew
like cause them pain
and so then there I was literally
shaming someone who kind of had like
unbeknownst to me like a disability with
their mouth you know yeah so maybe
there's something like that going on
there's that possibility but there's
also the possibility that you're dealing
with a slob who was never a
child and if that's the case
do what my brother just why don't you
just say this are you a slobber do you
have a disability
what if the after that the guy said am I
chewing yeah right it's happened dude it
happened before I you talking about my
chewing I
um I have a friend that chews absolutely
disgusting no condition no no like that
or just like I honestly
I don't even want to describe it because
it's going to make me feel disgusting
yeah okay okay fair yeah and I said ah
you too all up huh
and he was like what and I was like
you're too up it's gross don't do
it like that right because it's
disgusting okay nice and he was like I
just chew like this I don't know man it
tastes good and I was like yeah but it's
disgusting for everyone right
and I got another guy and I was like
that's disgusting right and he
was like oh you chew kind of with your
food up front and you know
it's disgusting yeah the whole
restaurant
the hostess gonna buy you dude people
from other restaurants you've been here
but you've been to mine before and it's
disgusting
um but yeah and so I did do that and uh
and I remind him whenever I see him he
doesn't change every time no no if I'm
eating I'm like ah yeah that's right I
forgot you two disgusting
the guy's married and like
what you got to change someone married
him I can't believe it to be honest I
can't believe dude I would never be able
to marry someone who should discuss it
with their mouth open good looking dude
great guy
funny
choose disgusting that's tough man yep
close everyone listening now pay
attention to how you chew if you happen
to chill with your mouth open
close it it's also not the
regular mouth open disgusting chew he
does he does a specific thing I think I
know I don't want to hear it
we owe it to the audience he leaves the
food
yeah in front of his yeah I knew it dude
and and you can see when he chews it's
in Fr it's in Fr it's in like it's dip
like oh my God that guy dude and
and it's disgusting anyway choose it you
can see the strings from up okay man
okay I'm just saying imagine I'm eating
tuna okay but I'm just I did already
okay
and I don't want I don't know why he
does that dude stop it who if he's
listening now I'll tell him I'll text
him about it does he know if he's
listening now does he know it's him I'll
text him right now see what he says
afterwards I'm not gonna say who it is
though
yeah so not not listening this oh okay
um all right well it takes a while I'll
update you all right
you chew up huh
up huh
do I know this person just yeah thinking
about it
I think I might know
do I maybe is it possible that I know
who it is maybe okay all right I'll see
what he says all right hey Chris and
Matt love the show I think it's a great
thing what you guys are doing thanks I'm
a long time listener but this is my
first submission so cool dude we'll see
how it goes anyways I have this family
member who
for the last six years myself and others
have been encouraging him to go to
therapy and anyways we're in this
loophole where he says he'll do it to
make us feel better and then never does
it um and he really needs it the last
update we got he had actually booked an
appointment which gave us some hope and
then I texted him the day of his
appointment asking him how it went and
he canceled it because it was a remote
session and he didn't think he'd get
anything out of it
now I've been to therapy remote and in
person
Chris I know you've been to therapy
maybe you could share some words of
wisdom
but I guess they advice I'm looking for
is just what do I do I know
in-person therapy is really hard to find
right now yeah wow
and yeah what do I do because he's
he's
very valuable to me like he's a this is
a relationship that I don't want to let
go
but he's not getting better and I he's
not pleasant to be around
and I just frankly don't like being
around him anyways
uh yeah
dude what do I how do you make somebody
do something that
they don't want to do yeah well anyways
uh thanks guys uh looking forward to
hear what you have to say the answer is
you cannot yeah you can absolutely not
make someone suicide
so that being said you've tried a number
of ways to get them to go to therapy you
think that'll make a difference if not
even if it doesn't make a difference
immediately you know it would be a
gesture signaling that he actually wants
to change and cares with his friends and
people close to him
think about him but like dude
you don't want to be around him he
doesn't want to do the thing you're
suggesting
I mean the solutions right in front of
you man you you got to stop hanging out
with this guy also that's just how it is
yeah if people don't want to change even
though you've suggested a number of ways
that they could possibly go about it and
they don't even want to try those things
that might result in them changing
they're going to come some
who's never been a therapy is going to
say oh no I don't think remote therapy
would work on me that's crazy you don't
know anything dude like he's
just going to come up with some excuse
and he's going to continue to come up
with those excuses so do yourself a
favor and move on from this dude this
guy's not a good friend you
don't like him you don't like being
around him I think he says oh everyone
your friendship just because you have
been friends as a family member it's not
oh he didn't say that because it's not
his family okay
no but it's good that you cut me off
four different times throughout the
thing I'm saying to make sure the wrong
thing you said something that wasn't
true but uh yeah dude you don't oh I
just hate I don't like when people think
yeah they like have you don't owe this
you don't need to be this person's
friend just because you have been this
person's friend if they're being a bad
friend then don't be their friend it's a
family member there shouldn't be such
thing as a bad friend because once you
start becoming a bad friend you're not a
friend anymore uh that's good I like
that thank you that's almost as good as
the saying go ahead and call the cops
I'll have sex with them it's up there
um
yeah you the other thing you can do is
try
and maybe you have tried this but work
the prescription
uh medic medicine
um what angle like you'd be like yo if
you go to this they could give you a
prescription to something that might
actually help you oh you could try that
angle be like that's how you can
directly benefit from it you know you
think you won't benefit from it from a
zoom session which is not true it's very
weird but also you know they could
prescribe something to you that could
absolutely help you so unless it's just
against medication or the whole thing in
which case Matt's right yeah dude like I
mean the guy it sounds like you love
this dude and that breaks my heart but
like this is a family member doesn't
change the advice man like if that
person's not gonna take a single step in
a direction to improve or address the
things that people around him who love
him are trying to
get him to address then like he's not
participating in the friendship or uncle
or son or brother because it's a family
member but yeah but yeah no the same
does same is true of a family member you
don't oh
your family your time like you just you
just you keep people in your life that
are good for you you keep people in your
life that you respect that respect you
back but you can't just keep someone in
your life just because you have been
friends with them up to this point
that's not a good reason yeah that can
count
extra yeah like if the Friendship is
still there exactly but it can't be the
only thing yeah
yeah when shit's Hanging On by thread
yeah all right
yeah cool
sounds good next
hey what up man Chris how you doing uh
Chris I saw you when you came to Sydney
like I don't even know how long it was
like 20 years ago by now please come
back soon you were hilarious
um and Matt thank you you are so funny
on lifeline and I think you give amazing
advice thanks for everything you guys do
thanks man my problem is with my
girlfriend
I love her to death but whenever we pick
a movie she refuses to give
good movies a chance you know she would
rather watch a shitty Netflix movie than
watch an actually decent movie I mean
I'm a big movie guy I studied film I'm a
big movie buff I personally believe that
all the best movies in the world have
already been made not to say new movies
can't be good right but let's be honest
all the best movies already exist sure
so whenever I'm trying to convince her
to watch you know
your matrixes your fight clubs size of
lambs pulp fictions whatever those kind
of movies she just won't do it she she
just doesn't want to watch him she
doesn't want to take a chance on them
and I know she'll enjoy them if she
watches them but it's just yeah I can
never convince her to just be like hey
just give it a shot I'm sure you'll like
it she would rather watch some yeah
shitty Netflix movie that came
out oh you know what I mean so it's
like what can I say to kind of convince
her to just take a chance on a movie
that I know she's gonna like right yeah
uh anyway yeah is it actually won't sit
through it because he starts slow thanks
buddy or is it that she just doesn't
want to yeah
then like you just gotta talk to her and
be like hey can you just please try this
yeah yeah you you will like it but I
feel like most movies that are really
great they usually start pretty slow
because you I feel like well I don't
know if that that's trying to think of
the movies he's mentioning I don't think
those they don't well Fight Club is very
boring I I don't like Fight Club but
beginning I think so but maybe people
don't I guess yeah fiction is and it has
no probation is but you know what dude
to somebody who's like into Tick Tock
and yeah sure well there is a whole
scene it's like that scene is long and
you're like what is this turn this off
until everybody it makes me mad that
someone would do that but they would 100
they would yeah I mean people turn
off in one minute so oh yeah you know
yeah
um so have you heard of the millennial
pause you know about this do you know
about this Chris what is it the
millennial pause no
so Millennials are now obviously like a
little bit older than like gen Z and
right and I think I'm a millennial
technically I think you might be 1980 is
the last year yeah uh and so I
definitely am yeah and
millennials
do something where when they're taking a
video of themselves to Post online
they
they take like a beat or a breath right
after they hit record
so they'll hit they'll hit record and
then they'll go
hey guys uh that little thing is
something that Generation Z and zinnials
say is like an annoying thing
Millennials do because it's like just
get to the video
whoa yeah dude really yeah if you look
it up and you'll pause and put it on the
thing yes I don't know if I don't know
if Anthony can because he kicked it out
he'll click on yeah all Maltese
Falcon right
p p a w s he writes oh look there's even
a Wikipedia thing he writes paws
sure
or just go to the wiki go to the
Wikipedia page yeah
um the millennial
is speaking
there's a pause in speaking that is
present at the start of summer recording
videos especially on short film video
app Tick Tock the practice of including
such a pause is generally ascribe to
Millennials a group often that's defined
to include people born in the 80s and
90s the phenomenon is example of the
digital generation gap between
Millennials and younger Generations
Taylor Swift does it that's funny that's
funny and she's obviously young but
she's still a millennial so like
we're considered well we including we
yeah in we is Taylor Swift which is
insane but we me you and Taylor Swift
three of us are all Millennials yeah and
we all probably do the millennial polls
and that makes younger people mad
because they have to make sure that it's
working that's hilarious it's half a
second I know yeah
dude apparently does it make them mad I
was reading a whole thing about it dude
like
generous disease I'll just keep swiping
if they don't start right away yeah if
they're not talking right away I'm not
watching
it's like oh I'm sorry
I'm sorry is your time so precious such
an old guy you know I'm sorry you got a
14. you got a whole bunch of
stuff to do you got a whole lot of
videos
the cares what you got to
do in your ass life I'm
gonna pause for as long as I
want in the line of fire
and The Tick Tock of fire dude in the
line of tick tock uh
why is
I mean how precious is your time
John Malkovich relax who gives a
they took a breath Taylor Swift
took a breath before video line
her up shooter
John markovic dude why do people not say
that uh
who's that guy
in pull up the cast of dope sick Peter
sarsgaard is that his name no that is
that him
he's a guy who I love yeah
um
Peter that guy right there still Borg no
right there sorry guard yeah what about
him
why you say Peter stulgaard Michael
stolberg is right next to him no Peter's
good that's the guy you like
what about him yeah that's cool that's
it no I'm kidding so so hold on so it's
Peter sarsgaard why don't people say why
don't a resounding uh amount I don't you
people say unanimously that he is John
Malkovich and John Malkovich is not John
Malkovich anymore because he's too old
and now Peter sarsgaard is John he's a
little I'll tell you why he's a little
more sensitive and the roles he's less
yeah it's less weird more like less
aggro explosive you're right you're
right Peter sarsgard's amazing
though you think I love him yeah I I
wouldn't say otherwise I just he's not
in a lot of that you know not he's
in a lot of weird like random ship
Peter sarsgard the only person
no no you are kind of a little bit Time
by John Michael which I'm not mentioning
him at all we're only talking about
Peter sarsgard right now you know I'm
that good of an actor right uh as who I
think you can see uh Peter sarsgaard's
in Kinsey that's correct that is
correct and I can act like that she's
seen it I would be in a movie where it
shows my I was in a movie no don't
break the internet but American animal
happens to be streaming on Paramount
plus it does don't all go over there and
flood the website and ruin it for
everybody trying to watch the new Beavis
and Butthead movie and all the other
what's up is your blurred out
probably it is I think it's probably
yeah yeah I don't know hey find out
American animal on Paramount plush it's
a great movie yeah watch it he's in it
and there's no if Matt's isn't it
thank you yeah my babadook is in it so
uh but yeah also uh Kevin Bacon's dick
is in wild things for no reason it's
just the rest of the show how do you
feel about that
um dick is in what I think Michael first
Willis's dick is in uh in the united
color a color of night the NC-17 version
only
theatrical cut
his cut his dick was cut out of it if
you know what I mean yeah they call that
the the uh circumcising circumcision
yeah
color of night was circumcised uh so
that movie got panned color of night
yeah yeah dude it said notorious is it
really bad though I like it I saw it Oh
okay man you literally just said ask me
how it was I started answering and
before I even got a word out you said I
saw it yeah that's the kind of stuff I
do yeah wow no I don't remember if I
liked it or not it was a long time ago
okay do you remember what it's about
like the plot kinda not really that's
crazy cuckoo stuff oh so that's why I
got made so what is it why did they show
his dick it's so weird it's a full-on
and they don't need sex Thriller yeah
it's like all about sex and
neuroses and weird sex personality
disorders Jane March
plays
do you want me to say two people in it
yeah I know that she plays a boy in his
Therapy Group he's a therap Bruce Willis
is a therapist in it and the woman
seducing him outside of the office but
isn't it the same person the whole time
yeah and he's and he doesn't know even
though Jane March is like a very sexy
beautiful woman so that's why and she's
in bad makeup and a bad wig his therapy
with like Brad dorif and him yeah and
we're not supposed to pretend it's not a
hot woman no everybody
you know yeah Brad dwarf is the man dude
I don't know who that is pull him up
Brad dwarf dude Brad dwarf is in that
scene that there's a clip of
congratulations where you're talking
about Nicholas Cage being the best actor
till the break of dawn baby he's in that
you know
he's great he is great yes he's amazing
yeah
yeah I knew that was a great guy Chucky
his daughter is also an actress and
she's also great she looks just like him
it's crazy really yeah
yeah man
what you gonna do
oh
what you gonna do see there you go
wow Quincy's dude wow how much is Brad
dwarf some guy that would stop you on
the street wants to ask for directions
oh yeah I mean I wish that was the
guy from dude I love Brad dorf
really God
yeah all right well well okay let's do
another one okay before we get out of
here
so it's curious
hey what's up Matt and Chris
got a question for Chris here
yo man when you're training working out
I don't know if you've ever measured
your body parts your legs your arms you
know to do you know
see how you've been growing I've
measured my arms and one arm is like
three quarters of an inch smaller than
the other arm is okay what would you do
for that you just curl more with the one
arm you just hope people don't notice
hit me up with that question well people
probably don't know
my fiance and I we're going to be
checking you out in Ottawa we actually
bought tickets hell yeah
still gotta sell it out though but we'll
be there see you guys so dick you know
saying I can't sell it off he's Auto was
the one I'm not I've sold out in Edmond
wait no yes Edmonton
Calgary
and Montreal oh no and Hamilton oh no
not Edmonton yet why the am I not
sold out in Ottawa
go figure dude I'll be there soon but yo
uh or wait no I'll probably already have
done it at this point with this out but
anyway I mean losing Millions on your
phone okay yeah but it's all good so uh
I mean it wasn't for me so yeah but also
it's very very obvious just do an extra
set or a few reps on the other one it's
too hard oh No One's Gonna Keep It on no
one notices what does this get someone
noticing no one notices anybody anywhere
ever I know and all the time I'd even
notice you sent in a video I didn't
notice anything was going on are we
doing a podcast right now I didn't even
notice I'm awake yet today I don't even
notice that
um I think yeah just do a few extra reps
obviously
that's so obvious so it's all good
ah it's just the most obvious thing in
the world
yeah
um what do we do to get your muscles
bigger is basically what you're asking
well how do I get one muscle to be as
big as another work the smaller one out
more John Malkovich okay work the
smaller one out more yeah dude okay
that's it dude get a trainer figure that
out you know
or just get just lift more weights with
that one there you go okay we can't
something too many different times yeah
I figured it out yeah okay that's the
end of the show what does this one air
though for real
uh that is Sunday the 24th okay so then
I will be in
yeah that well I've already done all the
Canadian dates so Pittsburgh Cleveland
Detroit Orlando Richmond Baltimore Fort
Myers Philadelphia Reading Pennsylvania
go go to uh krista.com
get your tickets and sign up for pitch
of Lifeline luxury that's patreon.com
Lifeline luxury uh where that show is
just us and it doesn't have to
do with we don't take submissions but
it's very fun go check it out don't
don't sleep on that uh we already have a
bunch of episodes there you go watch
them all
um if you had a question go to the link
link below watch lifedun.com or leave
the message and uh one-on-one advice
sessions with matalia matalia.com and
then get the merch that hot beautiful
merch it's winter so get a bunch of it
is at lifelinemerge.com
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]